So, I'm not depressed now, but I was depressed for a long time and I wrote about being depressed
and I lived for a long time with blinding depression and had long stretches when everything
seemed hopeless and pointless, when returning calls from friends seemed like more than I
could do, when getting up and going out into the world seemed painful, when I was completely
crippled with anxiety and when I finally got better and started writing about the process
of recovery, I became very interested in all of the different kinds of treatment that there
were for depression and having started as a kind of medical conservative thinking that
there were only a couple of things that worked, medication and certain talking therapies
and that that was really it, I very gradually began to change my mind because I realized
that if you have brain cancer and you decide that standing on your head and gargling for
half an hour every day makes you feel better, it may make you feel better, but the likelihood
is that you still have brain cancer and you're still going to die from it.
But if you have depression and you say that standing on your head and gargling for half
an hour makes you feel better, then you are actually cured because depression is an illness
of how you feel and if you feel really great after you do that, then you're not depressed
anymore.
So I began to think all kinds of things could work and I researched everything ranging from
experimental brain surgeries to hypnotic regimens of various kinds, I had people writing to
me because I had been publishing on this subject, there was one woman who wrote to me and she
said that she had tried actually electroshock treatments and a variety of other approaches
to depression, medication and therapy and she had finally found the thing that worked
for her and she wanted me to tell the world about it and that was making little things
from yarn, some of which she sent me and none of which I'm wearing right now, but in any
event I had that rich engagement and I also became interested as I was doing this work
in the idea that depression existed not only in the civilized west as people tended to
perceive it to exist but actually across cultures and had existed across time and so when one
of my dearest friends, my friend David Hecht who was living for a little while in Senegal
said to me, do you know about the tribal rituals that are used for the treatment of depression
here?
I said no, I don't know about them but I would like to know about them and he said well if
you come for a visit we could try to do some research on this topic and so I set off for
Senegal and I met David and I was introduced to David's then girlfriend, now ex-wife Ellen
and it turned out that Ellen had a cousin whose mother was a friend of someone who went
to school with the daughter of a person who actually practiced the ndop and that I could
therefore go and interview this woman who had practiced the ndop and so we went off
to a small town about two hours outside of Dakar and I was introduced to this extraordinary
old large woman wrapped in miles and miles of African fabric printed with figures of
eyes and she was Madame D'Youff and we did an interview for about an hour and she told
me all about the ndop and at the end of it feeling rather daring I said, listen I said
I hope, I don't know whether this is something you would even consider I said but would it
be possible for me to attend an ndop and she said well I've certainly never had a foreigner the
local word was to Bob I've never had a foreigner attend one of these before she said but actually
she said I mean you've come through these friends and these connections she said yes the next time
I perform an ndop you may be present and I said that's fantastic I said when are you next going
to be doing an ndop and she said oh it'll be sometime in the next six months and I said six
months is quite a long time for me to stay here in this town waiting for you to do one I said is
there anyone who might maybe we could expedite one for somebody move it forward I'll pitch in
she said no it really doesn't work that way she said I'm sorry but that's that's how it is and
I said well I guess I won't be able to see an ndop then but even so this conversation has been
so interesting and so helpful to me and and I I'm a little sad leaving here about not actually
getting to see one but but I thank you and she's well I'm glad that you could come I'm glad it was
helpful and she said but there is one other thing she said I I hope you don't mind my saying this
and I said no what what is it and she said you don't look that great yourself she said are you
you are suffering from depression and I said well yes I said I was very acute it's kind of a little
better now but yeah I still do actually suffer from depression she said well I've certainly
never done this for a tuba before but I could actually do an ndop for you and I said oh I said
what an what an interesting idea I said well um yes sure yeah absolutely yes let's let's let's do
that I said that I'll have an ndop and she said oh well that's great she said and she gave us some
sort of fairly basic instructions and then we left and my translator the aforementioned then
girlfriend now ex-wife of my friend turned to me and she said are you completely crazy do you have
any idea what you're getting yourself into and I said well you know I'm all these things very
interesting she said you're crazy she said you're totally crazy but I'll help you if you want so we
had left and the first thing we had was a shopping list there had been a she had you could get them
to buy the stuff but you had to pay a surcharge I'd said no we'd buy the stuff so we had to go
out we had to buy seven yards of African fabric we had to get a calabash which was a large bowl
fashioned from a gourd we had to get three kilos of millet we had to get sugar we had to get cola
beans and then we had to get two live cockerels two roosters and a ram and so Ellen and I went
to the market with David and with these other people and we got most of the things and I said
well but what what about the the ram and Ellen said we can't buy the ram today what are we gonna
do with it overnight so I saw the sense of that so the next day the next day we got into a taxi
to go back out two hours to where we were going and I said what about the ram and Ellen said oh
we'll see a ram along the way so we were going along and going along and there was a Senegalese
shepherd by the side of the road with his flock and we stopped the cab and we got out and we
bought the ram for seven dollars and then we had a little bit of a struggle getting the live ram
into the trunk of the taxi cab so but the cab driver seemed not at all worried even by the fact
that the ram kept relieving himself in the trunk of the taxi cab and so then we got to Rufi's can
we got there so here I am I'm ready for my close-up and the thing about the end up is that it varies
enormously depending on a whole variety of signals and symbols that come from above so we have to go
through this whole shamanistic process and I still didn't know really very much of what was gonna
happen so first I had to change out of my jeans my t-shirt and put on a loincloth and then I sat
down and then I had my chest and my arms rubbed with millet and then which is a grain and then
someone said oh we really should have music for this and I said oh great and I thought you know
drumming I thought some atmospheric thing and she came out with her very prized possession which
was a battery-operated tape player for which she had one tape which was chariots of fire so we
started listening to chariots of fire and in the meanwhile I was given sort of various shamanistic
objects I had to hold them with my hands and drop them I had to hold them with my feet and drop them
I they would sort of say oh this augurs well this augurs badly there were five assistants to Madame
Diouf who had all gathered around and we sort of spent the morning like this and it was all really
just fine and then they said it was maybe we'd started at about 8 maybe about 11 11 30 they said
well now it's actually time for the the central part of the ritual and I said oh okay and the
sound of drumming began the drumming I'd been hoping for the drumming began and so there was
all of this drumming and it was very exciting and we went to the central square of the village
where there was a small makeshift wedding bed that I had to get into with the ram and I had been told
it would be very very bad luck if the ram escaped and that I had to hold on to him and that the
reason we had to be in this wedding bed was that all my depression and all my problems were caused
by the fact that I had spirits in Senegal you have spirits that have all over you the way here you
sort of have microbes some are good for you some are bad for you some are neutral anyway my bad
spirits were extremely jealous of my real-life sexual partners some of whom are here tonight and
and that we had to mollify the anger of the of the spirit so I had to get into this wedding
bed with the ram and I had to hold the ram very tightly because he he was not having a good life
this ram and he of course immediately relieved himself on my leg and the entire village had
taken the day off from their work in the fields and were dancing around us in concentric circles
and as they danced throwing blankets and sheets of cloth over us and so we were gradually being
buried and it was unbelievably hot and it was completely stifling and there was the sound of
these stamping feet as everyone danced around us and then these drums which were getting louder
and louder and more ecstatic and more ecstatic and I was just about at the point at which I
thought I was going to faint or pass out at that key moment suddenly all of the claws were pulled
off I was yanked to my feet the loincloth that was all I was wearing was pulled from me the poor
old Rams throat was slit as were the throats of the two cockerels and I was covered in the blood
of the freshly slaughtered ram and the cockerels and so there I was naked totally covered in blood
and they said okay that's the end of this part of it and I said well okay and they said but you they
said we're actually we but there's the next piece comes now and I said okay and we went over back
to the area where we've done the morning preparations and one of them said but look it's it's kind of
lunchtime why don't we just take a break for a minute would you like a coke I don't drink
coke that much but at that moment it seemed like a really really really good idea and I said yes
and so I sat there naked and completely covered in animal blood with flies kind of gathering as
they will when you're naked and covered in animal blood and I drank this coke and then when I had
finished the coke they said okay now we have the sort of final parts of the ritual they said so
first you have to put your your hands by your sides and and hold your stand very straight and
I said okay and then they tied me up with the intestines of the ram and in the meanwhile it
was hanging from a nearby tree and they were there were some instead of doing some butchering of it
and they took various little bits of it out and then I had to kind of shuffle over all tied up in
in intestines which most of you probably haven't done but it's hard I had to shuffle over and I
had to take these little pieces of the ram and I had to dig holes and I had to put the pieces of
the ram in the holes and I had to say something and what I had to say was actually to me incredibly
strangely touching in the middle of this weird experience I had to say spirits leave me alone
to complete the business of my life and know that I will never forget you and I thought what a kind
thing to say to the evil spirits you're exercising that I'll never forget you and I haven't so anyway
there were various other little bits and pieces that followed I was given a piece of paper in
which all of the millet from the morning had been gathered I was told that the next morning I should
sleep with it under my pillow and in the morning get up and give it to a beggar who had good
hearing and no deformities and that when I gave it to him that would be the end of my troubles and
then the women sort of all filled their mouths with water and began spitting water all over me
which it turns out is the sort of you know it's the surround shower effect and rinsing the blood
away from me and it gradually came off and when I was clean they gave me back my jeans and everyone
danced and they barbecued the ram and we had this dinner and I felt so up I felt so up it had it had
been quite an astonishing experience even though I didn't believe in the animus principles behind
it all of these people had been gathered together cheering for me and it was very exhilarating and
I had a very odd experience five years later when I was working on my current book and I was in
Rwanda doing something else altogether and I got into a conversation with someone there and I
described the experience I'd had in Senegal and he said oh you know we have something that's a
little like that he said that's West Africa this is East Africa it's quite different but there are
some similarities in some rituals here he said you know we had a lot of trouble with Western
mental health workers who came here immediately after the genocide and we had to ask some of them
to leave and I said what what was the problem and he said okay they came and their practice did not
involve being outside in the Sun like what you're describing which is after all where you begin to
feel better there was no music or drumming to get your blood flowing again when you're depressed
and you're low and you need to have your blood flowing he said there was no sense that everyone
had taken the day off so that the entire community could come together to try to lift you up and
bring you back to joy he said there was no acknowledgement the depression as something
invasive and external that could actually be cast out of you again he said instead they would take
people one at a time into these dingy little rooms and have them sit around for an hour or
so and talk about bad things that had happened to them he said we had to get them to leave the
country thank you